after working for a decade in an
automotive industry I realized that the
semiconductor domain will suit my career
plans but entering the domain was not
easy I needed to have the knowledge
about data handling analysis and the
course I did from Simply learn taught me
the basics of it not just that I changed
my domain and I got an hike of 110
percent in my new company hey my name is
rakshat Ramesh and I'm originally from
Andhra Pradesh I did my high school in
Andhra Pradesh and I was playing
basketball for under 16 in state level I
moved to Bangalore to do my graduation
and start my career here in my previous
company I was working for an automotive
domain it was going great but I wanted
to grow professionally and explore my
opportunities I did research and found
semiconductor the Mind fits my career
goals but I lacked sufficient knowledge
about data science so I decided to go
ahead with simply learns data science
course which taught me the basics of
python also as we all know in the
semiconductor tools there'll be a lot of
data which should be captured and to
have have the meaningful analysis of it
this course helped me a lot it's because
of this course I got this new
opportunity and my new company I joined
as in software program lead engineer
where I am working for Semiconductor
industry and also here I got an hike of
110 percent I believe to be expert in
data science this course will be very
much helpful as we all know the complete
industry is evolving into AIML tools the
simply learn course will be helpful in
shaping my career I'm a people's person
I'm part of a motivational speech team
where I deliver motivational speeches
for the people who are in need of it as
they say there is no substitute for hard
work I believe there is no substitute
for upskilling if you have to try new
things and be good at it